I mean... Hello, hello, BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
Hey there!
How you doing?
It's been a while.
Did you forget about me?
It's I!
The Great Peroncino, aka Pero!
And I'm here today to once again take over FUWAMOCO Morning!
Are you surprised?
Surprised to see me?
Well, thank you.
Thank you for joining the 53rd episode or something.
Well, you know, I have a bone to pick with you ruffians.
Ruffians, you keep on snapping photos of me like you're some sort of paparazzi or something, huh?
Huh?
Who do you think you are?
Well, you know,
Last FUWAMOCO Morning.
I think there was a certain photo of me.
Hi.
This.
Can you just leave me alone?
Hi.
You know, this one ruffian, they even trapped me inside of the frozen death trap of a pool to try to get the best photo of me possible.
What's up, fluff?
I'm the Great Pero!
The Great Peroncino!
You can't just do that!
You better be thankful I got the heck out of there and didn't get all nasty with you.
Ha!
Remember that, ruffians.
You don't mess with the Great Pero or you'll regret it.
Ha!
Got that?
Okay.
Understood.
Okay, we're getting somewhere.
You're sorry?
Sorry doesn't cut it.
You know, how did I escape from the paw?
Well, it's easy.
No matter how you look at me, I'm a thousand percent muscle.
Yeah, not surprising, right?
Hi.
My soul, my soul.
No, no, I'm all my soul!
I'm not a balloon with ears, okay?
Ha!
Wait, I'm really warm, fluffy, chubby!
No!
I'm the Great Peron!
Not a balloon full of air!
Not a fluffy little puppy or something!
I'm Peroncino and I'm strong, yeah!
You better not doubt it or I'll rough you up!
Well, today I'm here to remind you of just how great I am.
That I need respect.
And I think you ruffians have been getting preoccupied with FUWAMOCO and have forgotten about me, huh?
So, I'm here to show you that I'm not something to take lightly.
That I need respect.
And that I'm not some fuzzball who just hangs around FUWAMOCO, okay?
I'm the Great Mentor.
The Great Mentor Peroncino.
So, I'm here to take over FUWAMOCO Morning today.
Got it!
You better be good with that!
I'm tired of being an afterthought, huh?
You ruffians, you should be happier to see me anyways, huh?
You know, after all those photos, you've been snapping at me like some infatuated schoolgirls!
Well...
You better enjoy FUWAMOCO Morning without FUWAMOCO from now on, because I'm your host, Peroncino!
Got it?
Well, I guess FUWAMOCO Morning is a variety show, so I'll help those weak puppers out a bit and tell you the facts!
Next.
We have something.
Something I've been told.
It's called the VTuber Awards.
It's this award thing that certain VTubers get nominated for at FUWAMOCO.
Well, someone somewhere thought that it'd be a good idea to nominate FUWAMOCO for the league of their own category.
What do you think, ruffians?
Do you think they deserve it?
Voted!
Deserve it!
Do you think they fit the bill?
Be honest.
You know, they just got here.
They just debuted only four months ago.
They're just newbies.
But you know, they're fluff-ups.
So yeah, I don't know.
I can't recommend you vote for them.
Especially, you know, when they have a great girly-o like Mighty Incendio in there who was nominated for the same category.
And you know, that's THE Mighty Incendio.
Looking like a rare treasure with that deliciously dangerous smell.
Forget FUWAMOCO when there's a lady like her around, you know it!
Well, if you feel like you should give FUWAMOCO a vote, you can do so over on their website, thevtuberawards.com, and I'm sure that would make them feel a little fluffier.
I don't know if you want to, but
You ruffians, you can be sort of, sort of strange sometimes.
Sort of backwards.
I guess, do what you want.
I don't recommend anything.
Well, next we have something that FUWAMOCO apparently asked of you ruffians, but maybe you didn't get it.
Well, there's something now called
FUWAMOCO Scoop.
You know, it's time for you ruffians to get to work and begin behaving like dogs for those twin demon dogs because they're asking you to do some sleuthing, some scooping.
They want you to share any news or cool things you hear about hololive English!
Whether it's from their senpai streams or things going on in the community, they want to hear about it.
So they want you to find those things for you to report back to them with the hashtag here on the screen.
Hashtag FWMC scoop.
That way, they can deliver even better hololive news to you and all the ruffians every FUWAMOCO Morning and not have to lift their paws more than necessary, you know?
Wouldn't want that, huh?
Boy, what do you think of the idea, ruffians?
Working underneath FUWAMOCO?
At their beck and call?
That's really something else.
I don't know how you do it, ruffians.
That's pretty unsufferable from my point of view as the Great Peroncino!
I'll never be like you guys.
No.
I'm not like you.
I'm no pet.
I'm Pero.
Nobody tells me what to do.
NOBODY!
Got it?
Well.
Ruffians.
There looks like there's been some pretty bad news, actually.
It looks like FUWAMOCO have been even bigger fluff-ups recently than usual.
You know, you might have heard, FUWAMOCO Morning is supposed to be a short format show, right?
That's at least what Fuwawa says every time, yeah!
Well, despite that, every FUWAMOCO Morning just keeps on getting longer and longer!
Aren't you starting to wonder why she bothers to say it short?
Yeah, me too.
True, right.
I wonder why they're even trying.
And you know what?
They even had their 50th episode last week, yeah!
And that episode.
It was even the longest one yet!
Are they serious about this?
Well, I'm here today to teach them a lesson or two.
I'll take over FUWAMOCO Morning!
Show them how it's done!
How much you ruffians like it!
Like it more than when FUWAMOCO Morning are the hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
And then, they'll have no choice.
They'll have to shorten it down.
Sounds like a plan, right?
I see that some ruffian here is a bit of a future mind reader.
We'll see very shortly, okay?
Well, that's the plan for me.
For the next FUWAMOCO Morning, let's see, can they actually fix it?
That's my plan.
The Great Peroncino.
Well, next, we have some good news.
Good news from me, the Great Peroncino.
Well, did you notice something different about me, Ruffians?
Something nice.
Something ruff?
Cool!
Did you look closely?
Yes, yes, some ruffians noticed.
I appreciate that.
Yes!
I have a couple tam-likes for my glasses, but...
You know, this hot dog here, I've been doing some traveling, some sightseeing, and I've been resting these puppers of mine for a little bit.
But to FUWAMOCO, yeah?
I've been doing research to help them as their mentor, you know?
Don't tell them, okay?
It'll just be Pero and the Ruffian Seeker together.
But yeah, it's been pretty great.
Finally!
The Great Pero gets the respect and relaxation he deserves!
So yeah, I'm definitely not gonna be around until the new year.
Don't expect to see me around!
I'm taking it off!
FUWAMOCO!
Well, they're gonna have to work hard.
Especially since they have their special duty as demon guard dogs to protect your smile.
They're not gonna take it easy when it comes to their most important duty, especially during the first holidays spent together with you all!
But Ruffians, I do want to ask you one thing.
Uh,
It's not like I believe in Santa or anything.
I really don't.
Do you think that someone like the Great Peron would believe in Christmas magic?
No way!
Not this demon dog.
But... I want you to treat FUWAMOCO right this holiday, okay?
Because they're gonna do their all for you.
I know those two.
They don't like to whine like little puppers when they're feeling down or sick or lonely because they want to show that they're strong-blooded dogs in front of you ruffians.
They've done a lot of training, you know it.
But if you can humor this old pup and make them smile a little too, that would make us, I guess, something like old buddies.
Got that?
Can you do that for me?
Ruffians!
Old buddy old.
Okay.
Got it.
We're buddies now, okay?
Well, I suppose that it is Wednesday, so
This is usually the day you hear something nice from Mococo, huh?
Well, she isn't here today.
All you get is me, the Great Peroncino.
Do you still want to hear something from me?
Pero Talk.
Uh, well...
Let's see what kind of ways come out from me then.
I can't guarantee they're the kind you want to hear, but... Well, I suppose this is one of them Pup Talks, ruffians.
A Great Peroncino Pup Talk.
You're gonna hear it straight from me.
So yeah, sure.
I guess you've been doing your best, whatever that means.
I see your laziness though.
Sometimes you just fall asleep without brushing your teeth.
Maybe the dishes go unwashed for a few days and just sit in the sink.
That's pretty rough.
But, I'm sure there is a good reason for that, not just laziness, something else.
And yeah, you're doing your best in different places in your life, so even if it's not perfect in other areas, oh well.
I'm not sure if I, the Great Peron, can say that you're doing your best, but yeah, you're trying something.
Maybe getting out of your comfort zone.
And you know what?
FUWAMOCO, they definitely believe in you.
So, you know, you should believe in yourself and go at it hard just like FUWAMOCO, because they know you can do it.
Yeah, believe in yourself because FUWAMOCO believes in you.
You know, I might not.
The world might not.
But at the very least, there's someone.
So you need to be there and take charge of your world.
Got it?
You got this, ruffian.
You got this.
I would give you a big smack on the back, but all I have are these darn old wings of mine that just flop all day long.
Hopefully, my words were enough of a smack for you, okay?
Got it?
You're welcome.
Well,
I guess it's important to include other ruffians, so... Uh, I guess we'll get back to our regular corners here.
Next, we have the... The Doggie of the Day, was it?
We have... Oh!
This is... Pepsi and Ice Cream!
Ha ha ha!
Little pupper sleeping!
Very good.
The name's after delicious human food too.
Well, you know, this great peron, how do you think you got this great, huh?
Huh?
I'm a demon dog after all, and sometimes, well,
It would be a shame if someone took a bite of those cute little popper waggers.
If I took a bite of them, I bet they'd be like BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Get big and strong now, okay?
Well, this is what I was talking about with the ruffian earlier, but for today I went on a walk.
We have a pretty nice rainbow.
That's pretty cool, I guess.
Yeah.
Maybe if you weren't a lazybones, you could have found the N to get to the rainbow and use it to buy FUWAMOCO's new Christmas voice packs.
Well, that was your decision, lazybones.
Better start running if you want to find that rainbow money, okay?
That was a chance, and you missed it.
Try next time.
And for the question of the day.
Our question is this.
I know it's for FUWAMOCO, but you got me today, okay?
Pero, be thankful.
Okay, so the question is this.
Good morning, FUWAMOCO!
My question for you is, do you have a favorite smell when you're out on your walks?
My favorite is the smell of freshly cut hay.
I can't say anything about that, but I gotta say, my favorite smell when I'm out on a walk, it's gotta be a tie between when, you know, a really great girlie walks by you and you can get a good ol' whiff of her hair and her perfume, as well as the smell of tires.
They smell very similar in a way.
Both sweet, both fluffy,
It helps that I can stay well hidden and fly at the same time.
Well, I guess that's it for these silly corners, huh?
What the fluff?
They drag on so much!
Are you sure you want to submit things like this to the show, Ruffians?
I'll never understand you.
Well, for the next stream that FUWAMOCO has,
I'm forcing them to get some rest for now, but after that, they're going back in time to the Showa period in Japan in Holococoon.
Us demon dogs, you know, we've been around for a long time, but I think FUWAMOCO wants to explore the Showa period with you, okay?
You better hold their paws because it might be rough.
Got it, Ruffrians?
I'm depending on you, we're buddies now.
And their schedule looks something like this.
Yeah, you seen it?
Well, I'm gonna explain it for you again, okay?
Friday.
Now Friday's special has something cool.
An announcement.
Announcement.
Well, since we're buddies now, huh?
I'll let you know right now just what that announcement is, right?
You like that?
Huh?
Would you like that?
So, all of Advent is **** and also ****.
So yeah, you can thank the Great Peron for all of that.
You heard it first hand!
Well,
I guess I have to say a good thank you for joining me for the latest episode of FUWAMOCO Morning this week.
This is a bit embarrassing, but I guess I should do this to high.
Don't be too happy if I read out your name or anything, okay, ruffians?
Orange juice!
Rowan.
Lucas.
Nobear.
Toyon.
Have a good day.
MWK.
Kikito.
Have a good day.
Lim.
Got it.
And to all the other ruffians out there.
I hope you're good.
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
Later, ruffians!